can I help you call you join me in the
parking lot
she's not like tonight it's your lady on
the other hand she looks just nice me
maybe we didn't understand my request
[ __ ] I guess
[Music]
no luck
I love where's the mask you don't eat it
anymore you've lived in the shadows long
enough I've been tasked with assembling
an elite team travel through time I say
we go get weird in the 70s now save the
world is full feels good
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
legends of tomorrow footage I just love
that the white canary is starting so
many bar fights like yeah let's get in
some trouble this is going to be fun
they've been releasing a whole bunch of
trailers for each of the characters it's
mostly just for people who have
naturally no idea who firestorm or the
white canary is now obviously the white
canary is a different character in the
comics so the caity lotz white canary is
really more like the arrow to green
arrow transition that Oliver's making
you know Black Canary are technically
she was just the Canadian she wasn't the
Black Canary canary to white canary just
like arrow to green arrow bloodlust not
quite as big of a deal that was what the
big arrow Constantine episode was all
about restoring her soul to her body and
yes I totally think that Constantine is
going to be back on arrow next year
maybe legends of tomorrow too but the
other thing I really love about this is
that it turns to captain cold and heat
wave the to do's that you would expect
to start a bar fight and she's just like
no no just pause I can totally handle
this and then later she's like okay yeah
maybe maybe now's the time zero
hesitation from Captain Cold is he
smiles throws his beers on the ground
turns to heat wave and nods yeah go time
part of me feels like they had to do a
bunch of takes of this scene because
Wentworth Miller kept laughing it looks
like he might had a hard time making it
through that scene just with that Bart
Simpson smile on his face like oh yeah
it's fun time a lot of you have
recognized from that boba fett trailer
where they're like oh you know one lousy
drink and you guys had to piss Boba Fett
off that is Chronos he's a big DC
time-traveling villain he's going to set
off the legends of tomorrow arc now
there was a big DC panel over the
weekend that you guys probably heard me
talking about during my arrow on flash
videos this weekend they mostly talked
about legends of tomorrow and the way
they're treating time travel is is that
the time masters rule is that you're not
allowed to go back to an event you
participated in a good example that is
the beginning of arrow season 3 where
Willa kills Sarah they couldn't go back
to that moment because they are
participated in that event participated
as in she took an arrow to the chest yes
Barry and Oliver are totally going to
crossover with the show but because
they're not officially on the team they
can travel two points in Barry and
Oliver's life they can go along their
timeline they tease that we would see
older and younger versions of flash and
arrow now the way they put it is flash
narrow they didn't say Oliver and Barry
so we are going to see Connor Hawke the
way they pitch that character is that in
a
future time why they didn't say how far
in the future in the future someone has
been inspired to pick up the mantle of
the green arrow who has fallen so at
some point in the future Oliver dies
connor hawke picks up the mantle we'll
get to see that happen as of right now
the furthest future version of the flash
we've seen is one season to flash in the
season one finale told season one flash
don't save your mother I think this is
season two flash right here so as of
right now that only be about five months
into the future so you know we haven't
really seen an old version of the flash
or even Wally West who at some point in
the future would presumably pick up the
mantle the flash of Barry Allen were to
die the one thing that they said they're
probably not going to get to in season 1
but maybe season two is seeing teams
from different periods in time so like
Legion of super-heroes in the future
probably going to be a season to think
we're seeing a version of the Justice
Society from the distant past or the
outsiders or some other big DC team
season 2 stuff and they did confirm that
because vixen is going to be a big
character in this arrow flash universe
that she might come on legends of
tomorrow if she doesn't get her own
live-action show they greenlit season 2
of the animated show if you didn't watch
it it's all on the CW see dats CWC calm
each season is like a half-hour episode
broken into six parts just because it's
really expensive for them to animate so
they said what they might do for season
two is find a place to air it as a
special online but that would have to be
in the fall just because it takes a long
time to animate it and they just started
finishing the scripts so Constantine and
vixen are two pretty solid picks for
Team additions in season two legends of
tomorrow now obviously nothing is
confirmed we are a long ways off from
season two so anything could change but
I think the idea with legends of
tomorrow especially when you see the
time masters trailer where punters like
let me assemble a team go back in time
with a Timeship is that rip hunter will
just assemble a different team based on
his needs we're fighting a certain type
of raid boss so I need a bunch of ranged
dps I need a tank etc you get the idea
different raid bosses require different
class balances I kind of already
explained the crossover with arrow and
flash now legend of tomorrow because
it's time travel they said it's really
hard to weave in with the narrative of
arrow and flash so arrow and flash will
largely be self-contained with with
their own plots like arrows fighting
Damian dark flashes fighting zoom
they're mostly going to focus on that so
when Oliver and Barry crossover
the legends of tomorrow they won't be
referencing Damien dark and zoom they'll
mostly be doing vandal savage stuff
hoping that gives you an idea and kind
of sets the context for time travel like
how come they don't go back to when
Oliver got shipwrecked and save his
father well because Sarah was there and
Sarah can't go back to a period in her
own timeline really this is all stuff
that they'll cover in that first episode
so they'll explain the rules of time
travel like terminator back to the
future rules you get the idea and
actually some really good news one of
the producers on arrow confirmed that
felicity is not going to become the
Oracle character they won't use that
name she's going to be in a wheelchair
for at least four or five episodes but
as expected DC and Warner Brothers is
bookmarking the Oracle name for
something else for some unnamed other
project there was this walkie arrow
Oracle type trail that i did a video for
yesterday so i'll put a link in the
description but really when you think
about it the only purpose of trailers is
to get you crazy so that you watch the
episode to find out what happened which
i think it is totally effective at doing
and just a quick reminder there is a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
going on this week all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video because everything
is coming back not this week but next
week they're probably gonna be dropping
a whole bunch of stuff so i'll announce
the winner whenever I post my next flash
video it's really crazy to think we're
pretty much there like arrow flash
legends of tomorrow all that TV all
coming back soon in Deadpool is coming
in less than a month so why guess wait
for all that's post you can click here
for that arrow WTF Oracle trailer and
you can click here for my flash zoom
video from last night thank you so much
for watching everybody let's have 5 i'll
see you guys tonight